no los olvidamos Ese es el mensaje que
el presidente estadounidense Joe biden
Busca mandar en su visita Puerto Rico
después de más de dos semanas de que el
huracán a tocar a la isla el mandatario
llegó al suelo el territorio libre
asociado para evaluar los daños y
anunciar ayudas por 60 millones de
dólares
venimos aquí en persona para demostrar
que estamos con ustedes todo Estados
Unidos está con ustedes mientras me
reciben se recuperan y se reconstruyen
Confío en que podemos hacer todo lo que
usted quiera gobernador y estoy
comprometido con esta isla
la visita de biden llega 5 años después
del huracán María quedó bastó la isla en
una tragedia que según muchos
puertorriqueños no tuvo la respuesta
adecuada por parte del entonces
administración de Donald Trump el miedo
de una situación similar se repite ahora
con Fiona que causó la muerte de al
menos 25 personas y dejó a la isla sin
electricidad unos daños que Siguen sin
revertirse por completo a un cerca del
10% sigue sin energía
al lado de Fiona Ian los daños del
huracán que tocó Florida como categoría
4 siguen apareciendo los equipos de
rescate han reportado que han visitado
45.000 hogares y negocios en las áreas
afectadas y los fallecidos ya son casi
un centenar las labores de rescate y de
restauración de la energía continúan en
este momento en todo el estado 95% de
los clientes tienen electricidad
hasta ahora hemos tenido más de 1900
rescates con los equipos de la unidad de
búsqueda y rescate que han ido puerta a
Puerta de 25 diferentes edificaciones
Florida espera la llegada de baile el
miércoles una en la que el mandatario
evaluará los daños en primera persona y
se espera que anuncien nuevas medidas
hacia la reconstrucción del estado